Peggy 18 hi my name is Michael Hampton
lead game designer on Assassin's Creed
rogue and I'm very happy to take you
through this first demo of our game our
hero Shay is an assassin turned Templar
who vows to bring down the assassins in
North America across three major
locations New York City the American
River Valley and here in the North
Atlantic Ocean along the coast of Nova
Scotia and Newfoundland in the south of
Canada this naval battlefield was at the
heart of the conflict between Britain
and France during the Seven Years War in
the 18th century and the outcome would
determine the fate of the American
colonies as a Templar you'll have many
opportunities to aid the British cause
against the French joined at times by
memorable characters from past
Assassin's Creed titles like Haytham
Kenway who you can see here on the left
in AC rogue you'll experience new and
improved naval gameplay Templars have
access to almost unlimited wealth so as
the captain of a Templar ship
the Morrigan you benefit from most
advanced weaponry at the age up ahead we
can see a restricted zone with French
military ships guarding let's attack
them now for attacking at long range we
can use the mortar next we can use one
of our new Templar weapons
the Karin AIDS which are front cannons
that fire explosive shots great for
stunning fast enemy ships you can also
combine them with the RAM used to charge
enemy ships at high speed and inflict
massive damage to their home the
Morrigan also has traditional weapons
like broadside cannons
damaging enemy ship will expose weak
points here you can use the popular
an early form of machine gun to destroy
wheat points in quick succession while
freeing
this ship is chasing us in these
situations
another new weapon the burning oil is
the best way to get rid of them as you
can see we leave a trail of fire behind
our ship that will burn all of our
pursuing enemies
the loot we have gained from this battle
can be used to upgrade our ship at any
time but for now let's continue to
explore the open world on the Left we
can see one of many French military
settlements that we can infiltrate each
one you can take down will aid the
British war effort and will often unlock
Templar missions for you to complete
inside will sail on to another location
this time the sapphire shipwreck located
further north in the Arctic to get there
we'll have to break through an ice sheet
that's blocking access to the area our
ship is already equipped with an
icebreaker round so we can cross through
it easily but this is an upgrade you'll
have to gain through your progression in
the story
looks like we'll under attack again
actions you take in the world have
consequences this time in the form of a
gang shell recognizable by its brown
sails and powerful RAM the gangs are
allies into the assassins and will hunt
you down when you have a high wanted
level the gang ship has managed to ram
us once a gang ship is rammed you the
enemy boards your ship and you'll have
to fight them off quickly to avoid
losing too many crew members one great
way to do this is to use the smoke bomb
to stun our enemies this allows us to
get a few quick kills in and gain the
advantage
here is their captain trained by
assassins he is highly skilled in combat
and difficult to take down let's see if
we could surprise him with the rope done
got'em with their captain dead the enemy
Cruiser renders now the ship is ours and
we have different options to choose from
this time we'll add it to our fleet and
promote one of our crew members to be
the captain we can now send the ship on
missions to help the British in the war
while sailing don't hesitate to destroy
icebergs in your path it can clear your
way but most of all
many have collectibles inside like
animus fragments and frozen cargo you
can also use them as temporary cover
during battles
in the distance we can see some of the
military activity which is found
throughout the North Atlantic Ocean in
the war between the French and British
you can help the British by freeing
their prisoners of war you'll have to
destroy two military ships escorting the
prisoner of warship without damaging it
otherwise the prisoners you're trying to
save will be killed but let's leave that
for now and continue on our way there is
also a harpooning site nearby there will
be many opportunities in the north
atlantic world to harpoon whales and
sharks hunting these animals will allow
che to craft unique weapons and armor
here is one of our new animals the
narwhal which is typically found in this
Arctic region for now let's continue to
our initial objective the frozen
shipwreck in the background we can hear
our crew singing there's around 20 news
shanties you can collect throughout the
game along with many of your old
favorites from Assassin's Creed 4 Black
Flag
the weather in the open world is dynamic
and in the Arctic you'll encounter
random blizzards which can seriously
affect your line of sight triggered
rogue waves and sometimes even tornadoes
finally we've arrived at our destination
the Sapphire shipwreck let's dock there
now
frozen shipwrecks are full of valuable
treasure so they're really worth
exploring
let's head over there and check out the
high point
you can also find hidden items like the
Templar armor in order to access it
you'll have to collect Templar keys
hidden throughout the game world
here we can see a polar bear it's too
far for us to reach now but he is part
of the unique wildlife which you can
hunt in the Arctic
okay
we made it now let's have a look at the
beautiful Northern Lights of the Arctic
we can spot a naval clash another
activity in the North Atlantic where we
can help the British and gain valuable
loot will stop the demo here we hope you
enjoyed this brief glimpse into the
exciting world of Assassin's Creed rogue
you
you